thanks for being here um yeah I'm happy
to be back in town I was commuting you
were commuting like crazy because you
shoot stuff for The Daily Show in New
York and you're shooting about a boy in
LA and you are on the plane must be on
the plane constantly it was every single
week I was flying back and forth and so
I'm happy to be here I physically I was
a mess and I'm happy I didn't end up on
a no-fly list as well why is that I
bring like a back of the plane mentality
to the first class all right so I bring
a Southwest attitude up to the front I'm
not like walking around you know
flipping over mimosas yeah anything but
but they're flying you when when when
business is flying you when like when
your job is flying you they tend to put
you up in these sometimes people put you
into nice seats and I feel like people
in them nice seats don't know the rules
on that you people in the back sort of
live by right I had a guy a really
really Italian wealthy like Italian guy
you know he could tell he looked like
Ralph Lauren yeah come in and I put my
window shade down because I was gonna
sleep and then you just the suede arm
just comes across and flips it up and I
had that I'm asking I flirt and I go
what are you what are you doing I guess
I would like the window up let me
explain how this works
all right I'm the window guy I control
the window right is what I'm paid for
this is what I selected I go you're the
aisle guy if I want to go to the
bathroom I wait until you have to go
that's how it works
yes yeah everyone knows he didn't know
the rules he doesn't know the rules they
didn't care and I said look I'm sure you
usually get what you want but it's not
happening today
I just yet I get really feisty I'm half
Mexican and I'm half Sicilian and I get
a little crazy and I get I gotta fight a
fight on the plane because somebody
pounded on the bathroom door while you
were in it I was in the bathroom and
somebody just pounds on the door yeah
Bert like when you you drink all night
and then you get on a flight did that
just decided not to go to sleep kept
drinking gone wasted so I was wasted
yeah I love it happens yeah do that yeah
and so I'm in there and everybody got
their meal and I decide now it's time
for me to go to the bathroom and so I go
bathroom I'm in there for as long as I'm
in there are we talking I I lost track
of time but I think I was in there just
for about three minutes
not that I'm the crazy okay three
minutes boom boom boom
and I immediately open up I go who did
that and the steward goes it wasn't me
and points to this guy who looks like a
mix between Jeffrey Tambor and Sam the
Eagle from the Muppets just we have a
still of Sandoz
forever ham so Justin mmm yeah and I
said hey I walk I'm still a little drunk
I go up to the guy and I go bang on the
door and he just looked at me and said
you were in there too long and I said I
was in there for as long as I was gonna
be in there I go when the red light is
on let me explain to you how this works
the red light is on you don't get up it
goes green then you get up I said if
it's an emergency
you walk to the back and he looks at me
and she says stick it I said stick it
who says stick it what are you the Fonz
you